hi everyone I'm Charley Heaton and these
are my essentials and you're going to
pass me them and I'm going to talk about
them all right
this is a watch and I feel like every
man needs like a good gentleman's watch
I've had about three different watches
this is a seventies Jaeger I was 18 and
I got my sister's my dad to chip in for
a birthday present for sixties watch
it's been taken since like 1964 and then
I ended up jumping in a pool with it and
breaking it this is my third one it's a
nice time for you soon
it's nice don't look at your phone the
whole time so you put your phone okay
I'm describing to you what a watch it is
this is crazy but yeah watch sunglasses
these are both crew to brand I really
like I just think these are really cool
polarized lenses and yeah they're cool
these are these and they're great and
you know side a I don't know they're
just some glasses but I know what to say
I mean you can look at these I chew them
so buy all the ends of these completely
chewed off in the same with this one
here yeah I'm really terrible with them
they're pretty scratched as well I'm
really bad at looking after sunglasses
but you have any just cheering them
while I'm kind of thinking just standing
this is pretty like it's just a little
special kind of thing I carry around
with me it's a little type in with a
boat on it my sister got me it for
Christmas and she kind of wrote a note
about it basically it's just a kind it's
like a memento of like to remind me that
life comes in waves like you know
all kind of whatever you're doing it
comes in waves so just to kind of you
know keep that on you and yeah I thought
was really sweet
token sometimes I'll wear it on my first
day of set just to keep me calm no I'll
just literally like stuff it onto like
you know a jacket or a jumper the most
probably important essential that I own
I am an avid Arsenal fan so wherever I
am doesn't matter what time it is when
they're playing but I have to get up for
most the game I'm the first one because
I'm from the altar so my dad and most of
my family are Leeds fans I wasn't into
football until I was roughly around 60
and I'd moved to London they were the
first team that I watched and I used to
play fifa a lot with my friends and they
were the team that had always picked so
they just naturally became my team we're
not doing that great at the moment so
it's kind of hard to be an Arsenal
friend right now but I really like this
jersey - am i calling it a jersey did I
call it a jersey it's definitely a shirt
a football shirt yeah
this is my satchel bag again a gift for
my sister from my 18th Christmas present
and yeah I use it everyday and it's
leather so it's great because the longer
you use it the better against what's in
it I mean mainly I'll just carry like my
computer I always have a book right now
it's Wonderland Avenue which is a
dinosaur remember and a notebook which
is just for Phinehas and my glasses the
prescription lenses
I've got shaver in here in a moment yeah
these are my super goes again it's just
something that I constantly carry around
like you know my shoes will switch but
I'll keep these and I'll just I mean
they you know you can stick them in the
wash or you just come they're relatively
cheap so I just keep buying a new pair
but I wear a lot of trousers and it's
nice to kind of dress them down just a
[Music]
shave or American cologne yeah I have to
this is like the one that I've had been
wearing since I was about 18 it's Prada
melona
it's kind of very clean and talky this
one is the LA bosun foul which is
something that I've just been introduced
to and it's travel size
my sister's boyfriend
Rory and I used to steal it this is when
I had no money and I used to steal
everything that he had he lived upstairs
so I steal his clothes and I started
watch from him and steal his perfume and
yeah when I first got one my first like
paychecks it was one of the first things
I bought but the thing about sense and
which i think is amazing is it's no
filter it goes straight to kind of is
the brain and the memory bank so you
smell like a specific perfume and you
can be like walking down the street you
smell something it'll remind you of that
specific person they'll be walking up
like a guy that smells like an
ex-girlfriend anyway I was against
getting beats because I know they're
kind of really popular and you know
there's such a well-known brand but I
ended up buying them and they have
changed my life and the best thing about
these is the battery life they've got
something like 36 hours of battery life
so I charged them like once a month and
they work great and they're kind of
noise cancelling which is good like yeah
everything that goes really quiet and
also they're good if it's cold as well
they have two zeros traveling I listen
to music all the time so I pretty much
have these around my neck
[Music]
big faith something like yeah when I was
younger I did I used to play in bands
and my dad he's a big Beatles fan so I
grew up on a lot of Beatles and then you
kind of find your own way in music this
is my electric toothbrush just traveling
all the time you got to keep safely it's
so much better than a manual and it
changed my life and somebody bushing
yeah yeah it's good night and morning
two minutes each time it has a little
thing on it actually where you it like
vibrates a certain way when you want
when you've done you two minutes so
that's pretty cool thank you for
checking out my essentials yeah thanks
for watching
[Music]